[Music]
can we just like stay up here all day it
is so crazy down there
spiderman is in fact peter parker
so peter do what do i owe the pleasure
when mysterio revealed my identity my
entire life got screwed up this is
hurting a lot of people i was wondering
if maybe you could make it so that he
never did
the entire world is about to forget that
peter parker is spider-man wait everyone
mj ned may should really stop tampering
with the smell
what just happened
be careful what you wish for parker
[Music]
hello peter
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we got our very first spider-man
no way home tv spot this tv spot came
out in germany and it does have a slight
bit of new footage that of course we are
going to be talking about in this video
but also the official poster for
spider-man no way home the one that we
have all been waiting for could have
also possibly been revealed in a very
unusual way the good news is it does
look like promotion for the film is
ramping up which means that second
trailer should be here kind of soon and
hopefully with this german tv spot we
get even more tv spots that give us a
little bit more footage each time but
with the marketing that sony has been
doing who knows but let's break down
this tv spot and talk about this new
poster and a big congratulations to
youtube user harrison coxson for winning
the spider-man action figure giveaway he
has already been contacted about the
prize and we are giving away another
spider-man action figure this one's a
little bit different but still really
cool that i think everybody's really
going to love if you want to enter to
win same rules just subscribe to my
channel and to cosmic culture and leave
comments on the videos so this official
tv spot that showed in germany is pretty
much just a brief summary of everything
that happened in the first teaser
trailer but it did include a little bit
of new footage it starts off the same
peter talking to mj peter going to dr
strange saying that it's affecting
everybody's lives one plot point that
we've learned throughout the last couple
of weeks is that peter and mj are going
to try and get into college and peter
and mj are trying to get into mit but
they don't get accepted because of the
whole peter parker's spider-man deal and
from what we've heard it doesn't really
affect peter that much that he can't get
in himself but he feels terrible that mj
can't get in because she is associated
with him this is going to be a big part
of his grief and sadness in the
beginning of noah home and this is
ultimately going to be one of the key
factors that drives him to go to doctor
strange and ask him to do a spell so he
goes to doctor strange and of course we
know what happens there but then this tv
spot shows us peter parker and strange
seemingly falling into the mirror
dimension now for those of you who are
not familiar with the mirror dimension
it is explained in doctor strange and
it's a parallel dimension that basically
allows the user to practice their
magical abilities and fight their
enemies without the public's knowledge a
sorcerer can go into the mirror
dimension and still observe the real
world without being seen and it's a
great place to practice advanced and
dangerous spells but it seems like peter
parker and strange are falling into the
mirror dimension right after he does his
spell so i'm very curious as to why and
i initially have two thoughts now
there's really not much context here but
this is what comes to my head one is
that the spell works and even doctor
strange can't remember who peter parker
is so he treats him in somewhat of a
hostile manner if the whole world
forgets he's spider-man and doctor
strange is included in that then doctor
strange is going to forget everything
that they went through from the start of
avengers infinity war to now then all of
a sudden he's going to randomly have a
person inside of a sanctum in what seems
to be a hidden part of the sanctum so it
is possible that he treats him kind of
aggressively and he throws him into the
mirror dimension just to simply question
him or fight him the other thought that
i have actually has to do with a fight
as well but this actually involves
doctor strange knowing who peter is from
what we know so far this spell is going
to kind of shatter the multiverse and
bad guys are going to be coming from
other universes then doctor strange is
going to imprison them this is where the
disagreement between peter parker and
doctor strange happens the villains tell
peter parker and strange that the last
thing they remember is spider-man
killing them so peter parker feels bad
about that and he wants to let the
villains free however doctor strange
wants to send them back but if he sends
them back that means they're probably
going to go right back where they came
from and die at the hands of spider-man
so peter parker and doctor strange fight
and they accidentally free them now last
week we did get some new photos of
doctor strange crossing his arms looking
out into the distance and this is
probably him looking at spider-man this
is probably him pissed off that
spider-man let the villains out and
there is a possibility that they still
don't quite agree on what to do and we
have seen that one scene where doctor
strange and peter are fighting on the
train and doctor strange is multiplying
the trains i'm wondering if this fight
takes place in the mirror dimension i'm
betting it does i'm betting strange and
peter fight in the mirror dimension and
that's the scene that we get all of the
trains multiplying because obviously
strange doesn't want everybody to see
him fighting spider-man everybody at
this point knows who doctor strange is
and i bet you they still know who
spider-man is they just don't know who
peter parker is if we listen carefully
to the spell on the teaser trailer and
this tv spot the spell is the whole
world is about to forget that peter
parker is spider-man it doesn't say that
the whole world is going to forget
spider-man himself but that peter parker
is spider-man so strange probably
doesn't want to be seen fighting
spider-man out in the public so he
throws them both into the mirror
dimension and it's honestly a good strat
because unless you have a sling ring
you're not getting out of the mirror
dimension so if you wanted to he could
simply trap peter parker inside of it i
am betting though since that it's doctor
strange who did the spell he does
remember who spider-man is and they are
simply fighting because peter parker
wants to free the villains either way
this scene in the mirror dimension is
probably going to be pretty epic and i
do believe it's going to be a fight
between doctor strange and peter so we
have our very first official spider-man
no way home tv spot but that's not all
last night we could have had the
official poster for spider-man no way
home revealed there was a spider-man no
way home poster spotted on a bus in
australia advertising the movie and this
is the poster that was shown now so far
it has not been identified as fan art we
know the hilarious situation that
happened before where theaters were
putting posters of fan art in display
for spiderman no way home since the
studios haven't provided them with
anything but this is an advertisement on
a bus the bus companies have no reason
to do a fake poster for spiderman no way
home and of course the advertisement has
to be paid for by somebody and again
since the bus company is not a movie
theater or involved with movies
whatsoever why would they put a fake
poster on there and if you notice
spider-man is in the same stance that
he's in in the trailer where he notices
doc ock or some other villain this is
where peter is standing on top of the
car he sees something coming in the
background at him and the iron spider
suit comes out this is the exact same
stance except the iron spider legs are
out and of course we can notice doc
ock's arms coming at peter now if this
is real it does seem like they're really
leaning into doc ock but that's really
the only official villain they've shown
and if sony and marvel really are trying
to keep everything a secret that's
probably all they're gonna show us even
though we did see the pumpkin bomb even
though we have seen the lightning from
electro and a brief brief clip of the
lizard and sandman they're still
probably going to be pretty vague with
their trailers and tv spots trying to
show us as little as possible but here's
the good news a new tv spot and a poster
means that production for promotion is
about to ramp up hopefully this means a
lot more tv spots and hopefully this
means sony and marvel themselves will
release an official poster and of course
all of this is a great sign pointing us
towards the actual official trailer
being released for spider-man now we
home hopefully pretty soon within the
next couple of weeks let me know what
you think about this new tv spot and the
poster in the comments down below do you
like the poster or do you not would you
rather it be something different let me
know what you think in the comments down
below don't forget to subscribe and like
the video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram twitter and tick
tock as always thank you all so much for
watching woof